[Musik]
wenn jemand vier mal ein kabel um den
hals geschlungen hat dass das ein fall
für die mordkommission und damit
begonnen wenn man so jemandem erdrosseln
echten bedarf es eines erheblichen haft
er hat er eine spezielle vorliebe das
war neben stricher und der pakte ja
eigentlich auf der überholspur und hat
dann die asylanten angesprochen
es war eine seiner alten leute
kennenzulernen die wo es eine videothek
oder solche geschichten einfach banale
fragen gestellt hat um ins gespräch zu
kommen um gottes willen erst erst erst
tod zwar ein klassischer sogenannte es
war kein mord mit dem mann hatte er
längere zeit die sex spielchen gemacht
also ich vertrete ihm bis heute noch
mehr überzeugt davon dass der keine
bedrohung für andere draußen darstellt
[Musik]